[Music]
i believe that to truly slow down you
have to change the way you travel
cycling allows me to travel more fluidly
to connect more deeply with my
surroundings
and i hope
with the people who call this place home
i'm michael george and i'm a national
geographic travel photographer
i'm exploring the scottish borders by
bike
my journey will take me from the heart
of this region out to the north sea
coast
i'm curious to understand more of the
area's history and how the region
inspired the legendary writer sir walter
scott
[Music]
well welcome to abbots for a tome of
walter scott built this home himself
with the proceeds of his writing
disaster struck when he was a toddler
because he contracted polio and because
of his infirmity he was quite lonely and
his imagination was fired with all the
stories of the borders shall we take our
travel back in time and i'll give you a
little bit of introduction to this great
house sure
[Music]
it's like a beautiful chaos you know i
think that's a wonderful expression that
a beautiful chaos is absolutely correct
but most importantly perhaps of the
shields that go round the ceiling
because these are the shields of the
families of the borders you have this
wonderful view of the magnificent river
tweed
scott was an environmentalist looking
after the landscape was something that
was very important to him and of course
many of these magnificent trees we see
in the natural landscape were possibly
planted by scot we don't know which ones
but we can just be grateful
with this gratitude in mind i head
further into the incredible cultural
tapestry of the area
[Music]
there is a warmth and honesty to the
people
even in your first meeting
it's as if you've known them all your
life
you arrive a stranger
but leave a friend
[Music]
the scottish borders is a place that
feels hidden
everything seems to be tucked away
but traveling more slowly allows for
gentler places to reveal themselves
the ruins of ancient abbeys
beautiful bridges across the river tweed
each place with its own magic
[Music]
moving through the ever-changing
landscape
woven with reminders of the region's
history
i am moved by how deeply connected the
people are
both to the past and to the present
peel towers
fortifications originally built to
protect the people from invasion and
capture
are now perfect
for capturing a photograph
[Music]
an ethos of conservation is evident here
from scott's dedication in planting
trees to today's wildlife preservation
at saint abs head national nature
reserve
hi there hi michael how you doing it's
nice to meet you i'm kira and i'm the
ranger here at centum's head yeah it's
so nice to meet you you too yeah it
seems nice and calm so let's keep an eye
out for dolphins and wales and so even
at this time you can see bottomless
dolphins quite close in how amazing yeah
so centab's head is a really heavily
designated site so it's a national
nature reserve which is is one of the
core purposes is to connect people and
nature and protect the nature as well
yeah the reasons why this site is
designated is for its assemblage of
wildflowers so if you come in midsummer
there's like carpets of pink thrift and
the sea of yellow from various flowers
rock rose and gorse and yeah it's
beautiful so we've got an amazing gray
seal colony here so
in just a couple of weeks time the first
pup will be born and from the little
lumper land up there and back to this
beach here there'll be over 1800 pups
spawn on the beaches
so in the summer the sea birds take over
so they completely fill the stacks the
noise the smell is incredible we've got
about 60 000 seabirds here
and really is an assault on all your
senses so i kind of feel the
responsibility on my shoulders to to
protect and conserve what's here to try
and provide the habitat
and try and protect it from anything
that's going to damage it or harm it
[Music]
the scottish borders is a place with
many stories to uncover
if you want to know more it's as simple
as asking
but to get the full story
you'll have to slow down
[Music]